[Music]
okay you're looking at the 31 kumicho I
like to practice it so it puts favorite
pressure on both the people doing the
practice it's often thought along the
distance further away but I prefer this
way so I'll be showing you my back I'm
going to split it up into the different
groups show the links between them and
finally show the whole thing okay so
this is 1 2 3 and the 31 QB Joe so feel
familiar with me Carter
they'll see me Robbie you guys in this
start position if he comes in deep
enough to scam me enough to move this is
gonna hit hard so there's no waiting
coming that big so you guys the blob
risks on the way in which goes through
into a full of arms flow which isn't
going to stop or it has sort of pullback
going before I for I pity the way a lot
people deal with these to sort of do a
just do a thrust they in some way here I
don't really like that because it kind
of sets the time to the rest of it the
part of practice that you're not really
doing anything so you can deal with that
by coming in going you go for the
initial thrust but then don't complete
it is to see the move from my side and
stop okay so we'll just go in and see
you
three so your pores are for each
movement so I might talk a bit through
some of them so first moves he thrusts
either wine taste movement in so this is
stop it I'm going to keep this tight to
the body moved today okay
that's a spiral smalls you shouldn't
come past the side but I gotta get my
entire body off the line so he doesn't
hit okay so Wow hitting draws back and
parries to space standard block three
disease at London County extra move so I
rotate strike out boy rotate back and
then three three
[Music]